Churchill en parlait comme
d'une énigme insaisissable,
auréolée de mystère.
Ce pays occupait un cinquième
de la surface terrestre,
s'est tiré d'est en ouest
sur près de la moitié du globe
et à l'est du pôle Nord,
aux frontières de l'Inde,
presque trois fois les États-Unis.
Plus de 22 millions
de kilomètres carrés.
Le soleil ne s'y couchait jamais.
Quand il faisait nuit à l'ouest,
dans la ville de Léningrad,
qui vient de retrouver son nom d'avant
la Révolution, Saint-Pétersbourg.
Le jour se levait
sur les frontières Est.
Sur les terres glacées
du détroit de Béring,
à 110 kilomètres de l'Alaska,
où la température passe
de 35 degrés en été à -35 en hiver.
Ce pays gigantesque
a été pendant 70 ans
l'Union des républiques
socialistes soviétiques.
Une immense terre
de contrastes et de conquêtes.
Le sous-sol renfermé
d'importants gisements d'or,
d'argent, de cuivre, de fer,
d'étain, de soufre, de magnésium.
Ces forêts couvraient
des millions d'hectares
et représentaient un quart
des réserves de bois de la planète.
On trouvait de la houille
et une des plus importantes
réserves de pétrole du monde.
Il y avait aussi du fer
et des aciéries
qui en tirer les outils de la paix
ou les armes de la guerre.
Des complexes sidérurgiques
comme celui de Magnitogorsk,
le plus grand du monde.
D'immenses plaines fertiles des steppes,
les terres de Géorgie et d'Ukraine
qui produisaient à foison céréales,
fruits, tournesol, coton
et où les machines
agricoles modernes
récoltait froment,
avoine, seigle, orge
afin de nourrir
250 millions de personnes.
Des troupeaux qui rivalisaient
avec ceux du Texas.
Du raisin, du tabac, du coton cultivé
dans les terres ensoleillées du Sud
et ramassées à la main.
C'était un pays très religieux,
mais le gouvernement
soviétique prônait l'athéisme
et avait remplacé
un dieu à l'image de l'homme
par des hommes pareils à des dieux.
On employait, parfois à tort,
le terme de Russie.
L'Union soviétique était en réalité
un ensemble de nationalités
qui parlaient 150 langues différentes.
Une véritable tour de Babel.
Comme cela a souvent
été le cas dans son histoire,
ce vaste territoire
et cette mosaïque de peuples
étaient dirigés
par un gouvernement central
à la fois sévère et généreux.
Les Russes,
descendants des premiers colons,
représentaient
la moitié des Soviétiques.
Mais l'Union soviétique
avait été constituée
en dépit des frontières
nationales et historiques.
Il y avait les Cosaques,
les célèbres cavaliers
du bassin du Dniepr.
Au Sud-Ouest,
les Ukrainiens,
dont les terres étaient auparavant
le grenier de l'Union soviétique
et qui a maintenant
formé un État autonome.
Leurs voisins,
les Moldaves,
qui descendent
des Roumains et non des Russes.
Et encore la Biélorussie
et la Bessarabie sur la mer Noire.
Et les vieux massifs
montagneux du Caucase,
avec leur mélange
de religions et de cultures.
L'Azerbaïdjan, l'Arménie,
la Géorgie, la Tchétchénie-Ingouchie.
Le grand désert du Turkestan,
l'Ouzbékistan, peuplé de musulmans
aux frontières du Pakistan
et de l'Afghanistan.
Les Mongols, descendants
des guerriers de Gengis Khan.
Les Turcs aux Tatars,
les Bouriates
et les Yakoutes
bien au-delà de l'Oural,
et enfin les peuples du Nord,
les chasseurs de Carélie,
les Lapons, les Lettons,
les Lituaniens, les Estoniens.
Les gens vivaient aussi bien
dans des Igloo que dans des chaumières,
des villages médiévaux
ou des villes qui n'ont rien à envier
à celles du reste du monde.
Moscou, par exemple,
avec sa forteresse,
le Kremlin, siège du pouvoir,
ou Saint-Pétersbourg, avec ses canaux
et son ambiance européenne.
La diversité culturelle et artistique
reflète l'histoire complexe de la Russie.
Pendant dix siècles,
ses nations et ses peuples
se sont unis, séparés, réunis.
On attribue au prince Riourik,
venu de Scandinavie,
la première Union russe en 862.
Une union toute relative
malgré un patriotisme profond,
un respect du passé
et une grande force spirituelle.
La Russie a toujours été
un pays composé d'individus
jeunes mariés, paysans, infirmières,
ingénieurs, laveurs de carreaux,
vendeuses, femmes au foyer,
employées de poste, speakers,
hôtesses de l'air,
scientifiques, dactylos.
L'histoire de la Russie
et de l'Union soviétique,
c'est une lutte incessante
entre la soif de liberté individuelle
et le besoin d'une force collective
conduite par un pouvoir autoritaire.
La Russie a été souvent
envahie au cours de son histoire,
au sud par les Mongols,
à l'ouest par les Goll
et un les Avars, les Bulgares.
En 1242, l'ordre
des Chevaliers teutoniques
envahit et occupa
la ville de Pskov au nord.
Sous la conduite
de leur grand maître,
les chevaliers allemands
réduisirent en esclavage
toute la population de la région,
y compris de la capitale Novgorod.
En cette ère de périls,
le peuple russe se tourna vers son prince.
C'était Alexandre Nevski.
Sous sa conduite,
les habitants de nombreuses
villes et principautés
se regroupèrent
pour repousser l'envahisseur.
Et le 5 avril 1242,
sur le lac gelé de Peïpous,
les forces russes unies affrontèrent
les combattants allemands très armés.
Les Russes n'étaient pas aussi
bien organisés ni aussi bien équipés.
La plupart des soldats
étaient de simples paysans ou marchands.
Ils réussirent néanmoins
à repousser l'agresseur
et la bannière allemande
disparut dans les glaces.
Les envahisseurs se noyèrent
par centaines dans le lac gelé.
Nevsky dit aux Russes que celui
qui frappe par l'épée périra par l'épée.
Après lui
vint le temps des tsars.
Le tsar Ivan III libéra
son pays du joug mongol.
Son petit fils devint
grand prince de Moscovie en 1533.
Suite à ses conquêtes
et à son autorité,
ce prince reçut un surnom signifiant
qu'il était redoutable et féroce.
Par la suite, il devint soupçonneux,
voire même criminel.
On l'appela Ivan le Terrible.
Ivan étendit le pouvoir de la Moscovie
aux provinces de Kazan,
d'Astrakhan et à une partie de la Sibérie.
Il contourna le pouvoir
des boyards, l'élite des princes,
pour le confier à des personnalités
locales issues des classes populaires,
celle-ci, abusait
souvent de leur pouvoir.
Ivan faisait confiance
à peu de gens.
Sa mère avait été empoisonnée
quand il était enfant
et la même chose était sans doute
arrivée à sa première femme.
Il était très autoritaire,
mais tenait compte de la Douma,
l'assemblée
des représentants locaux.
Ce personnage contradictoire
s'était autoproclamé
tsar de tous les Russes.
Pierre le Grand
était brillant et violent.
Fasciné par la beauté
et la souffrance,
il mit en déroute
l'envahisseur suédois à Poltava
et permit la création
de la première marine russe moderne.
Fasciné par l'Europe,
il décida de construire Saint-Pétersbourg.
Il en parlait comme
d'une fenêtre ouverte sur l'Europe
et engagea des architectes
français et italiens
qui conçurent une ville
dont la beauté et l'élégance
surpassent celles
de Venise ou d'Amsterdam.
Les édifices portent toujours
les armoiries de la famille Romanov.
La dynastie commença avec
Michel Romanov en 1613
et elle comprend
Catherine Première,
une domestique que
Pierre le Grand avait épousée,
qui prouva qu'une femme pouvait
diriger la Russie en étant ferme et juste.
Catherine II,
la grande d'origine germanique,
fut une des impératrices
russes les plus respectées.
Elle avait confisqué
le pouvoir à son mari débile.
Elle correspondit avec Voltaire.
Elle encouragea l'émergence
de la littérature russe,
mais aggrava le sort des serfs et fit
la guerre à la Turquie et à la Pologne.
Elle annexa la Crimée,
mais les conflits entre
le gouvernement russe
et la population locale,
puis l'intervention de la Turquie,
de l'Angleterre et de la France menèrent
à la sanglante guerre de Crimée de 1854.
Elle dura trois ans et fut
un désastre pour les troupes russes
et leurs vieux fusils à pierre
contre les fusils anglais modernes.
En 1807, après avoir perdu contre
Napoléon la bataille de Friedland,
le tsar Alexandre Iᵉʳ
signa un traité de paix.
Sur un radeau amarré à Tilsitt.
L'Empereur français appréciait le tsar
et avait même songé à
épouser sa sœur pour former une alliance.
Mais cinq ans plus tard,
Napoléon traversa l'Europe
pour conquérir la Russie
avec sa grande armée
composée de 500 000 hommes.
Ils traversèrent tout le continent,
mû par la soif de pouvoir
inextinguible de l'empereur français.
Mais l'armée du tsar,
dirigée par le général Koutouzov,
priva Napoléon de sa victoire.
Moscou fut incendiée.
On pratiqua la politique
de la terre brûlée,
ne laissant rien que son immense
armée put voler ou manger.
Mais bien des guerres
et des révoltes
allaient ensanglanter
le siècle d'histoire à venir.
La révolution industrielle
du 19ᵉ avait atteint la Russie.
Au début du XXᵉ siècle,
le pays reposait
essentiellement sur l'agriculture.
Malgré l'abolition du servage
en 1861, sous Alexandre II,
les paysans vivaient encore
comme au temps d'Ivan le Terrible.
Un travail mécanique
pratiquement inexistant,
une main-d'œuvre bon marché
et les propriétaires
terriens qui s'enrichissaient.
L'expansionnisme
de l'Allemagne impériale
entraîna de nouveau
la Russie dans une guerre.
Malgré les liens de famille
unissant la reine Victoria,
l'empereur allemand et le tsar,
leurs relations se détériorèrent.
La complexité
des traités de défense
et l'hostilité historique
de la Russie et de l'Allemagne
laissaient présager qu'ils
se retrouveraient dans des camps opposés.
Pour affaiblir le pouvoir du tsar,
les Allemands
soutenaient le révolutionnaire
Vladimir Ilitch Oulianov, dit Lénine.
Il était secondé par
Lev Davidovitch Bronstein, dit Trotsky,
un orateur persuasif et véhément,
ainsi qu'un excellent organisateur.
La Russie était en état de siège,
à l'intérieur comme à l'extérieur,
et Lénine avait sa propre interprétation
des œuvres de Marx et Engels,
et particulièrement du Capital.
Selon Marx, dans les pays industriels,
la classe ouvrière allait se soulever
contre les patrons capitalistes
et créer le communisme.
Selon lui, une pareille révolution
ne pouvait se produire en Russie,
insuffisamment industrialisée.
Lénine, lui, plaçait ses espoirs
de révolution dans la paysannerie.
En décembre 1916,
un complot de militaires et
de nobles décida d'assassiner Raspoutine
afin d'affranchir le tsar
de son influence et de sauver le trône.
Cela ne servirait à rien.
Les grèves spontanées, les manifestations
d'opposition continuèrent.
Nicolas II abdiqua.
En février 1917,
après une révolution peu sanglante,
la Douma se réunit à un gouvernement
provisoire démocratique fut constitué.
Des militaires
rejoignirent la Révolution
partout de Saint-Pétersbourg,
jusque sur les lignes de front.
On but, on célébra l'événement.
Le peuple était libre.
La guerre allait bientôt s'arrêter.
Ce serait la fin des puissants,
de la police secrète, des privations.
Le nouveau gouvernement provisoire
était chaotique, composé de Tsariste,
d'anarchiste se méfiant
de toute forme de gouvernement,
de militaristes, partisan d'un État fort,
de modérés favorables
à une démocratie à l'anglaise,
de gauchistes comme les mencheviks
qui voulaient donner
le pouvoir aux travailleurs.
Le parti bolchévique de Lénine appelait
à donner tous les pouvoirs aux Soviets.
De petits groupes radicaux
qui suivaient la ligne du parti.
Un avocat éloquent, Alexandre Kerenski,
prit la tête de ce gouvernement instable
et dut faire face
à des attaques continuelles.
Les bolcheviks
interrompaient les réunions,
demandant à Kerenski
de remettre le pouvoir aux soviets.
La tentative de coup
d'État d'un général de droite
conduisit Kerensky à relâcher plusieurs
centaines de bolchéviques emprisonnés.
C'était une erreur.
Mue par les promesses
de Lenine la paix et le pain,
les bolcheviks,
sous la direction de Trotski,
s'emparèrent du palais d'Hiver
et Lénine, prit le pouvoir.
En russe bolchévique
signifie majoritaire.
Ce n'était alors pas le cas.
Lénine savait que son parti ne pouvait
pas gagner des élections libres.
Leur résultat
aurait été beaucoup plus nuancé.
Pour faire de
sa révolution une réalité,
Lénine ne pouvait tolérer
ni compromis ni divergences.
41 millions de personnes votèrent
lors des premières
élections nationales de l'histoire russe.
Les bolcheviks ne recueillirent
qu'un quart des suffrages.
La nouvelle assemblée se réunit,
vota contre les propositions bolchéviques
et proclama une République
démocratique et indépendante.
Le lendemain,
l'assemblée était encerclée par l'armée.
Une autre figure
sortait de l'ombre Joseph Staline.
Lénine et ses partisans
craignaient toujours
le retour du tsar
Nicolas ou d'un héritier.
Pour mettre un terme
à la dynastie Romanov,
Nicolas, Alexandra
et leurs enfants furent exécutés.
Leurs corps furent jetés dans
un puits et brûlé à la chaux vive.
Le bruit courut que la princesse Anastasia
avait échappé à l'assassinat.
Non,
les Romanov n'existaient plus.
La mort continuait à frapper
massivement sur le front.
Il y eut en tout plus d'un million
700 000 morts du côté russe.
Le gouvernement allemand
avait soutenu Lénine
lui fournissant de l'argent pour
ses brochures, ses affiches, ses journaux,
ses opposants ont souvent déclaré qu'il
était à la solde de Wilhelm Strasser,
mais Lénine était simplement pragmatique.
Il acceptait l'argent de l'ennemi,
quitte à lui tourner le dos
quand il n'en aurait plus besoin.
Sa femme Kroupskaïa
partageait son engagement
et elle vécut avec
Lénine l'exil en Sibérie.
Le peuple payait un lourd tribut
à la guerre civile
des bolcheviks sabotaient des trains de
ravitaillement destinés aux Russes blancs.
À la demande de l'Armée blanche,
un corps expéditionnaire
américain occupa la Sibérie.
Le gouvernement soviétique n'allait
jamais oublier cette invasion américaine,
même si aucun coup
de feu n'avait été tiré.
Certains militaires
défendaient la nouvelle République.
D'autres restaient fidèles
aux idéaux du tsar et à la patrie.
D'autres encore hésiter
entre les politiques
de Lénine, Kerensky et la Douma.
Les Blancs fidèles au tsarisme
combattaient l'Armée rouge,
composée des partisans
des idéaux communistes.
L'Armée rouge tirait peut être
son nom comme la place rouge,
d'un adjectif
qui signifiait autrefois en Russe belle.
Le rouge symbolisait
aussi le sang des patriotes,
comme sur le drapeau de bien
des pays ou figure cette couleur.
Usant de manœuvres,
Lénine rassembla suffisamment
d'ouvriers,
d'intellectuels et de militaires
pour le soutenir
dans sa course au pouvoir.
L'homme chauve à la barbiche
devint le symbole
de la liberté et de l'utopie à venir.
La guerre continuait,
les soldats russes reculaient
ou rentraient
tout simplement chez eux.
Connaissant l'importance
de l'antisémitisme en Russie,
Trotsky, qui était juif,
avait offert à Lénine de se retirer.
Lénine, qui appréciait son intelligence
et son dynamisme, refusa.
À Brest-Litovsk, Trotski négocia avec
les Allemands un traité draconien.
La Russie perdait les pays
baltes, l'Ukraine, la Finlande
et une partie du Caucase.
Mais elle n'était pas
en position de discuter.
Lénine voulait signer
la paix avec les Allemands
et arrêter la guerre afin de renforcer
son influence sur un gouvernement fragile.
Les gauchistes voulaient
étendre la révolution à l'Europe
pour éliminer l'influence capitaliste.
Les partisans de la droite étaient
prêts à se battre jusqu'au dernier
contre une armée allemande honnie.
Les modérés demandaient
une paix digne et une république
dans laquelle tous
les peuples seraient représentés.
Moscou devint capitale,
mettant une distance
entre Saint-Pétersbourg, lazariste
et les rêves d'avenir socialistes.
En 1922, une hémorragie
cérébrale écarta Lénine du pouvoir,
mais pas du devant de la scène.
Des affiches ou figurer
les héros de la révolution
jouait le rôle de nouvelle icône.
Lénine y était le plus représenté.
Pendant 74 ans, on verrait
ces portraits partout,
jusque sur les paquets de cigarettes.
Un temps, Trotsky fut lui aussi adulé,
jusqu'à ce qu'on décide de le supprimer.
Les pays voisins de la Russie
devinrent des États socialistes
et fin 1922,
les républiques furent réunies
dans l'Union
des républiques socialistes soviétiques.
Nationalistes modérés
et même gens de gauche
étaient désormais ses ennemis.
Félix Dzerjinski
devint chef des organes de sécurité.
La Tchéka fut créée par
une police secrète dont la brutalité
dépassait même celle
de l'Okhrana du tsar.
La prison, les chaînes,
les exécutions, l'exil en Sibérie
que le tsar avait fait subir à Lénine
étaient des peines et une peur courantes.
La Tchéka devint ensuite la Guépéou,
puis le NKVD,
le MVD et enfin le KGB.
Contrairement à ce qu'affirmait
la propagande,
Lénine, se méfier de Staline.
Et jusqu'à sa mort en 1924,
il exprima dans sa correspondance
sa crainte que Staline
n'abuse pas de son pouvoir
s'il prenait les rênes du nouvel État.
Staline était un grand manipulateur
et alors que le pays
pleurait ses morts,
lui, il rassemblait ses fidèles
pour éliminer ses rivaux.
Le corps embaumé de Lénine devint
un monument au nouvel ordre socialiste,
installé dans un mausolée
de marbre sur la place Rouge.
Trotski était
en désaccord avec Staline,
son ministre Molotov
et le chef de la police secrète Beria.
Les affiches représentaient
des paysans et des ouvriers heureux,
mais tous les partis sauf
le Parti communiste, furent interdits.
Toutes les décisions devaient être revues
à la lumière de la pensée de Lénine
dans l'interprétation
qu'en faisait Joseph Staline.
Staline invoquait sans cesse
le nom de Lénine.
Pourtant, il perdait de vue
les idéaux de la révolution,
devenant un tsar communiste.
Les contestataires,
devenus des ennemis de l'État,
étaient écartés du pouvoir,
emprisonnés ou exécutés.
Staline décida que son pays
devait être débarrassé des opposants,
y compris des premiers révolutionnaires
comme Zinoviev, Kamenev ou Trotski.
Trotski fut écarté.
On réécrit l'histoire
pour occulter son rôle dans la Révolution.
Jusqu'aux photographies
qui furent retouchées
pour l'éliminer de la mémoire russe.
Staline lui ordonna de quitter le pays
pour soutenir le communisme
et combattre Staline,
Trotski voyagea en Turquie,
en France, en Norvège,
puis au Mexique, ou il finit par
s'installer dans une propriété gardée.
En 1940, un agent de Staline
fit irruption dans son bureau
et l'assassinat
à coups de pic dans le crâne.
Purges politiques,
faux procès, assassinat.
Les Occidentaux, voyez le Kremlin
comme un palais mystérieux
où régnait le mal et la conspiration.
En réalité, c'était le cœur
et le cerveau de l'U.R.S.S.
ses murailles abritent
la cathédrale de la Dormition
ou les tsars étaient couronnées
par celle de l'archange Michel
ou furent enterrées les tsars.
Le Grand Palais,
édifié au début du 19ᵉ
et refait pour abriter le Soviet suprême,
le Soviet des nationalités,
des musées et des bureaux.
Le Kremlin tout entier
relate la saga de l'histoire russe.
Les palais tsaristes furent conservés
pour rappeler
la folie dépensière des tsars,
mais aussi
comme un objet de fierté.
L'écrivain Maxime Gorki disait:
cette beauté témoigne
de la grandeur de l'âme humaine.
C'est notre histoire, notre fierté.
Le sol dans lequel s'enracinera
notre nouvel art national.
D'autres arts furent encouragés
par les communistes,
malgré les restrictions.
Serge Diaghilev
fonda le Ballet moderne en 1901.
Des œuvres de Tchaïkovski
comme La Belle au bois dormant,
Casse-Noisette et Le Lac des cygnes
furent interprétées par
les Ballets russes et le Ballet de Moscou.
La tradition fut poursuivie
avec le Ballet de Moscou
qui donna des stars internationales
comme Rudolf Noureïev
et Mikhaïl Baryshnikov.
Le compositeur Igor Stravinsky
révolutionna la musique
avec Le Sacre du printemps.
Les plans quinquennaux de Staline
des années 20 et 30
engendrèrent des réalisations techniques
ou utilités et splendeur se rejoignaient.
Par exemple,
pour le métro des grandes villes,
loin d'être purement utilitaires,
comme à New York ou à Londres,
les stations de métro russes ressemblent
souvent à des musées vivants
avec leurs peintures, leurs sculptures
et leur architecture soignée.
Cette réussite technique et esthétique
fut un véritable coup de maître
pour le ministre
des Transports Nikita Khrouchtchev.
En 1927, moins de 10%
des membres du Parti communiste
avaient reçu une éducation supérieure
et les paysans illettrés étaient légion.
L'École fut déclarée obligatoire.
Les leçons évoquaient toujours
les fondateurs du socialisme Russe,
Marx, Engels et Lénine.
À ce panthéon vint s'ajouter
une autre divinité, Joseph Staline.
Mais ce dieu ne se déplaçait
qu'en limousine blindée.
En 1928, Staline lança
l'industrialisation du pays.
Un plan quinquennal
a signa des normes irréalisables,
mais qui stimulait
une population épuisée par la guerre.
De gigantesques centrales
hydroélectriques furent construites.
Les syndicats furent interdits.
On ordonna aux ouvriers
d'augmenter leur production de 100 %.
La production de pétrole
et d'acier augmenta effectivement,
mais resta très
en deçà des prévisions.
On trichait.
La production réelle
restait identique ou baissait,
mais sur le papier,
les normes étaient atteintes.
Tour à tour maussade ou sociable,
convaincu du bien-fondé de son projet,
Staline était une sorte de tsar
pour le meilleur et pour le pire.
Basé à Moscou, le Komintern,
l'Internationale communiste
essayait de disséminer
la révolution dans le monde entier.
Il faut dire que le désespoir
engendré par la crise de 29
rendait le communisme très attirant
pour tous ceux dont la vie avait été
brisée par la faillite du capitalisme.
Dans les années 30,
des centaines de milliers de personnes
adhérèrent au Parti
communiste américain.
Mais dès que certaines réformes
furent adoptées,
comme celles de l'aide sociale,
le nombre d'adhérents chuta.
Dans les années 50, il ne comptait
plus que quelques irréductibles.
En Allemagne,
Adolf Hitler écrivait :
quand nous parlons
d'un nouveau territoire,
nous devons penser à la Russie.
Le destin lui-même
nous montre la voie.
Hitler joua sur la fierté allemande
pour provoquer la guerre.
Une revanche à l'humiliation
de 1918 et appliqua le nazisme,
un régime dictatorial
fondé sur la fierté nationale,
l'antisémitisme
et bien sûr l'anticommunisme.
l'U.R.S.S. adhéra à la Société des Nations
dans l'espoir d'éviter la guerre.
Alors que certains pays
réclamaient l'usage de la force
pour stopper l'agression,
l'Allemagne, l'Italie et le Japon
ont quittait la Société des Nations
pour régler les conflits
à leur façon par la guerre.
En 1939, Staline choqua nombre
de ses partisans sincères
en signant un traité
de non-agression avec l'Allemagne.
La Russie put ainsi gagner du temps
pour préparer sa défense,
cela permit aussi
à l'Allemagne d'envahir l'Autriche,
la Tchécoslovaquie puis la Pologne.
La marche vers l'est
des nazis fut interrompue
par la déclaration de guerre de
la France et de la Grande-Bretagne.
Les Allemands se
retournèrent vers l'ouest,
envahissant la France
et harcelant l'Angleterre.
L'État major de Hitler se servait
pour faire sa propagande.
L'idée socialiste d'égalité
était quelque chose
qu'Hitler ne pouvait supporter
et encore moins tolérer en Allemagne,
c'était contraire
à sa croyance en une race supérieure.
Les ennemis traditionnels
de la Russie,
la Hongrie, la Roumanie,
la Bulgarie et la Yougoslavie
s'allièrent bientôt à l'Allemagne.
Le gouvernement réactionnaire hongrois
dirigé par l'amiral Horthy,
la Roumanie gouvernée
par le jeune prince Michel,
mais secrètement manipulée
par le pro allemand Antonescu
et la Bulgarie,
où régnait le roi Boris
qui partageait les idéaux
du national-socialisme,
tous se soumirent aux nazis.
Quand les peuples de ces pays
se soulevèrent,
leurs dirigeants invitèrent rapidement
les Allemands à venir rétablir l'ordre.
Le temps pressait pour Staline,
l'U.R.S.S était entourée d'ennemis
à l'Ouest et craignait le Japon à l'Est.
Les usines toutes neuves destinées
à construire les outils de la paix
allaient devoir
fabriquer les armes de la guerre.
Dans toute l'U.R.S.S., on mobilisa
des hommes pour servir dans l'Armée rouge.
Beaucoup furent fiers de le faire,
mais des milliers
refusèrent de combattre
pour un pays qui
ne leur offrait aucune liberté.
Le front nazi s'étendait de la mer Noire
à la Finlande et à la côte de la Baltique.
Lors de la guerre éclair, les armes
allemandes avaient prouvé leur supériorité
sur celles de tous les autres pays,
la Pologne, la Tchécoslovaquie, la France.
La machine nazie
semblait impossible à arrêter.
Le 22 juin 1941, les nazis attaquèrent
cinq régions en même temps.
C'était le début de la bataille de Russie.
Plus de 2 millions d'hommes,
200 divisions
s'élancèrent sur un front
de plus de 3000 kilomètres
pour anéantir l'Armée rouge
et rayer l'URSS de la carte.
Le gouvernement fut évacué à Kouïbychev,
à plus de 1000 kilomètres à l'est.
Hitler clama que l'ennemi avait été brisé
et ne pourrait jamais se relever.
Les nazis avancèrent,
occupant 800 000 kilomètres carrés
du territoire russe,
l'équivalent de la taille du Middle West.
La vieille politique de la terre brûlée
priva les troupes allemandes affamées
de nourriture et d'approvisionnement.
Les immenses plaines russes faisaient
obstacle aux troupes qui approchaient
et les anciennes cités devinrent
de véritables champs de bataille.
Dans chaque ruelle,
on tirait.
Dans chaque maison
on s'embusquait.
Disposant de peu de grenades,
les Russes en improvisaient à partir
de bouteilles d'essence
et de chiffons enflammés.
Elles furent baptisées
cocktails Molotov,
en référence au ministre
des Affaires étrangères de Staline.
Odessa,
la ville de la révolte de 1905,
fut assiégée par
les Allemands pendant deux mois.
En tenant la ville,
les Russes empêchaient
le front nazi de pénétrer en Crimée.
Les soldats et les habitants
de Sébastopol,
la base navale de la mer Noire,
résistèrent avec un grand courage.
Il y eut huit mois de bombardements,
de pilonnages et de tirs
et de nombreuses victimes.
L'Armée rouge
s'accrochait à son port,
rue après rue,
maison après maison.
l'Armée nazie
et l'armée communiste
se battaient pour leur pays
et leur propre vie.
L'Armée rouge
donnait une leçon de vulnérabilité
à l'invincible armée
de la race supérieure.
Des millions d'Allemands périrent.
L'assaut continuait
malgré la censure du Kremlin,
les Soviétiques savaient
que la situation était désespérée.
Ce n'est pas une guerre ordinaire,
c'est celle du peuple russe tout entier,
et pas seulement
pour éliminer le danger qui nous menace.
La propagande familière
des affiches avait pris un ton nouveau.
Elle prônait la haine de l'envahisseur
appelé à la résistance.
L'égalité des sexes
était désormais une réalité.
Dans ce pays patriarcal,
les femmes combattaient
et mouraient aux côtés des hommes
pour défendre la mère patrie.
Quand elles battaient en retraite,
l'Armée rouge emportait
tout ce qu'elle pouvait.
Nourriture, véhicule,
matériel, le reste était détruit.
La grande centrale hydroélectrique
d'Ukraine, fierté de Staline,
fournissait beaucoup d'énergie,
d'où faciliter la conquête nazie.
On choisit de la détruire
plutôt que de l'abandonner aux Allemands.
Staline utilisait le sentiment national
pour consolider l'effort de guerre.
Que le courage de nos grands ancêtres
vous inspire dans cette guerre,
disait-il au peuple.
Et il rappelait la formule
qu'Alexandre avait prononcée
700 ans auparavant celui qui
frappe par l'épée périra par l'épée.
Le rude hiver russe
fut à nouveau un obstacle à l'envahisseur.
Les églises et les synagogues
fermées par le gouvernement athée
furent de nouveau ouvertes
pour donner force,
réconfort et ardeur au combat.
Les civils devinrent
de véritables guérilleros,
sabotant les camps nazis,
détruisant les voies ferrées,
montant des embuscades.
Il y avait plus
d'un million de déserteurs.
Les nazis avaient promis
l'indépendance à des républiques
comme la Lettonie, l'Estonie,
la Lituanie, l'Arménie, le Turkestan
et des milliers de gens
préféraient la promesse nazie
à la dictature communiste.
Après la guerre,
ils furent emprisonnés,
déportés ou exécutés
pour collaboration ou trahison.
Les victimes étaient innombrables.
Toute une génération d'hommes
fut anéantie pendant cette guerre.
Le second conflit mondial
en moins de 25 ans.
À nouveau, il arrivait
aux survivants d'envier les morts.
Les filles russes
avaient souvent été violées,
torturées ou mutilées
par les soldats nazis.
La réaction des Russes fut violente.
Les collaborateurs
furent capturés et pendus
et pour certains, cette vengeance
restait encore trop douce.
Moscou, Leningrad
et même la ville récente
de Stalingrad se préparaient au combat.
Les enfants participaient eux aussi.
L'hiver rigoureux,
un blocus total
et des bombardements
constants décimèrent les habitants
de Leningrad et Stalingrad.
Les gens mouraient
de froid dans les rues
où se terrerait
dans leurs chambres gelées.
Enfin, une voie de ravitaillement
fut ouverte et le siège fut rompu.
La vie recommença
dans les villes encerclées.
Une contre-offensive massive
repoussa l'armée allemande,
épuisée dans les plaines russes,
puis en Pologne,
dans les pays baltes
et enfin jusque
dans les forêts de l'Allemagne.
Lors de la conférence de Yalta,
Roosevelt et Churchill
laissèrent à Staline les pays baltes
pour qu'ils jouent le rôle
de tampon en cas d'agression.
Staline s'engagea à autoriser
des élections libres
dans les territoires occupés
et à entrer en guerre contre le Japon.
Les forces alliées prirent
et occupèrent Berlin,
laissant à l'Armée rouge
le temps de savourer son triomphe
et de se venger.
Les prisonniers allemands
furent contraints de défiler
dans les villes russes
sous les huées de la foule.
La victoire suscita
une fierté et une joie méritée.
En Russie, on ne parle pas simplement
de la Deuxième Guerre mondiale,
mais de la Grande Guerre patriotique.
Bien que sa stratégie ait coûté la vie
à des millions de ses compatriotes,
Staline fut acclamé
comme le sauveur de son pays.
Des monuments à la mémoire
des millions de victimes
furent érigés dans tout le pays.
La tradition voulait
que les jeunes mariés
s'y arrêtent
pour leur rendre hommage.
Les habitants de l'Union soviétique
pouvaient enfin souffler
et se tourner vers l'avenir.
Quatre ans après les États-Unis,
l'Union soviétique fit exploser
sa première bombe atomique.
Le communisme dominait
l'Europe de l'Est
et le rideau de fera inquiété
les puissances occidentales.
Le peuple reconstruisait les villes
détruites par quatre ans de guerre.
Staline, désormais vieilli,
voulait un pays aussi moderne
que ceux de l'Ouest,
sans les inconvénients que cela supposait,
comme la libre expression.
Beaucoup de femmes
travaillaient dans des domaines
habituellement
réservés aux hommes.
Non seulement
pour des raisons d'égalité,
mais aussi parce que
la population masculine avait été décimée.
Le portrait de Staline flottait toujours
au-dessus du pays, en chantier,
l'oeil inquisiteur.
L'Industrie était propriété de l'État,
entièrement dirigé par celui-ci,
sans avantages financiers
en perspective.
Les ouvriers étaient peu motivés
et les normes imposées par Moscou
les incitait essentiellement à tricher
et à travailler le moins possible.
Pour que les étudiants ne perdent
pas le contact avec la classe ouvrière,
ils devaient en plus travailler
en usine dans les kolkhozes.
Il y apprenaient le plus souvent
à s'enivrer dès le matin.
La consommation de vodka
était ahurissante
en moyenne d'une quinzaine
de litres par an et par personne.
L'alcool était responsable des deux tiers
des accidents de la route.
Le niveau de vie augmentait.
Les portraits de Lénine
étaient encore omniprésents,
comme pour rappeler à quel point
la vie s'était améliorée depuis les tsars.
Mais la nouvelle génération
avait soif de biens matériels.
On les trouvait parfois au Goum,
le plus grand magasin du monde,
qui était censé tout vendre,
des bonbons aux chaussures
en passant par les articles
de sport et les oignons.
Les boutiques et les galeries
n'étaient pas chauffées
et les files d'attente étaient longues.
Dans tous les commerces,
on comptait sur des bouliers,
les machines à calculer
et les caisses enregistreuses
étaient pratiquement inconnues.
Dans les restaurants,
les pourboires étaient interdits.
Cela aurait été la marque
d'une distinction sociale impensable
dans une société sans classes.
Sous Staline, l'armée était une
des rares exceptions à la pauvreté.
Une carrière militaire
signifiait toujours un meilleur logement,
un meilleur salaire et des chances
d'avancement inexistant dans le civil.
En 1945, le Japon
avait capitulé devant les Alliés,
mais l'Union soviétique
ne lui déclara la guerre
qu'après le bombardement d'Hiroshima.
La Corée avait été divisée
le long du 38ᵉ parallèles.
Les Alliés et les soldats soviétiques
l'occupaient ensemble.
Jusqu'en 1949,
la partie nord était communiste
et la partie sud
avait un régime fascisant.
Quand les troupes étrangères
quittèrent le pays,
les deux parties
se séparèrent officiellement,
chacun des gouvernements
prétendant être le seul légitime.
Le 25 juin 1950,
l'armée du Nord envahit le Sud.
L'Union soviétique restait prudente,
elle vendait à la Corée du Nord
des armes et du matériel,
envoyer des conseillers,
des techniciens, des pilotes,
mais sans que l'Armée rouge
participe directement au conflit.
Le gouvernement de Corée du Sud
se tourna vers les États-Unis,
puis vers l'ONU.
L'U.R.S.S. avait participé à la fondation
des Nations unies en 1944.
En tant que membre permanent
du Conseil de sécurité,
un vote condamnant la Corée du Nord
équivalait à trahir un allié communiste.
Voter contre la condamnation,
c'était approuver la guerre.
La délégation soviétique
ne fut pas présente lors du vote.
La guerre de Corée continuait,
mais l'URSS gardait une certaine distance.
Les troupes de l'ONU
repoussèrent les Coréens du Nord
jusqu'aux frontières
de la Chine communiste.
Une contre-attaque chinoise
chassa de nouveau les Alliés vers le sud.
En 1953, l'équilibre était exactement
le même qu'au début, en 1950.
Les avions à réaction,
qui survolaient la Corée, la bombardaient,
faisaient des missions
de reconnaissance des combats aériens,
les premiers de ce type.
L'Union soviétique fournissait
des MIG à la Corée du Nord,
des avions très maniables
qui se perfectionnent au cours du temps.
Les ingénieurs russes travaillèrent
pendant des décennies sur le MIG
jusqu'à ce qu'ils égalent
et même en certains points dépassent
les avions de combat américains.
Staline mourut en 1953.
Son corps fut placé
à côté de celui de Lénine,
mais certains prolongeaient son influence
pour servir leurs propres desseins,
comme le sénateur McCarthy
qui spéculait sur la peur du communisme.
Au Kremlin, les dirigeants
intriguaient pour le pouvoir.
Ce fut Nikita Khrouchtchev
qui devint premier secrétaire
du Parti communiste.
Il prenait la tête de l'U.R.S.S.
Il dénonça les crimes de Staline,
les assassinats, les purges, le mensonge
et des serrer l'étau
qui opprimer le peuple.
La première religion,
le christianisme orthodoxe russe,
avait été imposée
par Vladimir de Kiev en 989.
Le catholicisme,
pratiqué essentiellement en Lituanie,
était loin d'être aussi répandu.
Persécutés durant les premières
années du pouvoir soviétique,
les chefs spirituels avaient vu
les Églises transformées en musée.
L'Enseignement religieux était interdit,
car l'autorité des prêtres
pouvait remettre en question
la soumission aveugle à l'État.
Officiellement,
la Constitution garantissait
la liberté de religion en URSS,
mais en fait
les impôts étranglés l'église.
La Chine de Mao modela
son état sur le modèle léniniste
allié de l'U.R.S.S,
au début des années 50,
Mao considéra les réformes de Khrouchtchev
comme une trahison du léninisme.
En 1958, Mao condamna l'U.R.S.S.
l'accusant d'être contre-révolutionnaire,
mais celle-ci n'avait pas renoncé
à son influence sur les pays voisins.
En juin 1956,
des manifestations en Pologne
furent réprimées
avec l'aide des troupes soviétiques.
Khrouchtchev se rendit à Varsovie
pour trouver un compromis pacifique.
La réaction au soulèvement hongrois
quelques mois plus tard
fut encore plus dure.
Le leader communiste
révisionniste Imre Nagy
prit la tête d'une véritable révolution
contre le régime fantoche et répressif
dans le but de s'affranchir de Moscou
et de transformer le communisme
que d'autres
voulaient tout simplement éliminer.
Les dirigeants du Kremlin décidèrent
de maintenir la paix par la force.
La répression du peuple
hongrois suscita partout
l'indignation
jusqu'en Union soviétique.
Il y eut des grèves,
des protestations
et le parti vit chuter son nombre
d'adhérents comme jamais
depuis la Deuxième Guerre mondiale.
Les Hongrois ne purent
résister à l'Armée rouge.
Le même scénario se reproduisit
douze ans plus tard en Tchécoslovaquie,
quand les troupes soviétiques renversèrent
le gouvernement communiste
modéré de Dubcek.
Dans les écoles soviétiques,
tout était justifié de façon idéologique.
L'Armée rouge était le libérateur et
combattait les forces du mal capitaliste.
Dans les études, l'accent était mis
sur les disciplines scientifiques.
L'Éducation était gratuite,
mais la compétition difficile.
Les étudiants qui ont raté leurs examens
se retrouvaient à des postes bien loin
de leurs espérances et de leurs rêves.
Ils cherchaient donc
à être les meilleurs.
Les ouvrages occidentaux
étaient essentiellement techniques.
Tout ce qui avait un contenu politique
était censuré ou interdit.
Deux grands journaux,
la Pravda, c'est-à-dire la vérité,
et les Izvestia, les nouvelles.
Les Russes disaient en plaisantant
qu'il n'y a pas
de nouvelles dans la vérité
et pas de vérité dans les nouvelles.
Les journaux clandestins
abordaient des thèmes interdits
dans la presse officielle.
La soif de savoir
triomphait même de la censure.
L'Université de Moscou, le plus grand
établissement d'enseignement du monde,
produisit une génération
de penseurs inventifs.
L'étude du marxisme
avait tendance à supplanter
les sciences sociales et humaines,
mais les sciences appliquées attiraient
la fine fleur de la jeunesse soviétique.
Sous Staline,
les scientifiques devaient prouver
que toutes les grandes inventions
avaient été faites par des Russes.
Ce délire cessa avec Khrouchtchev.
De grands progrès furent accomplis
dans la théorie de l'atome,
la chimie, la métallurgie
et en électronique
où les découvertes furent appliquées
à l'industrie et à la défense.
Une des réalisations soviétiques
les plus spectaculaires fut Spoutnik.
Après 1945, les Soviétiques,
comme les Alliés,
utilisèrent les scientifiques
allemands prisonniers
pour travailler sur
leurs propres programmes spatiaux.
Les V-2, les fusées allemandes
porteuses d'explosifs,
donnèrent le coup d'envoi
aux fusées à propulsion.
Des deux côtés du rideau de fer,
les scientifiques rivalisaient
pour être les premiers dans l'espace.
Le programme américain fut marqué
par une série d'échecs.
Les Soviétiques, eux,
gardaient leurs erreurs secrètes.
Le 4 octobre 1957,
ils accomplirent un exploit
en mettant en orbite autour de la Terre
une sphère métallique
de 83 kilos virgule six.
C'était Spoutnik,
une simple radio
émettant un bip régulier,
mais qui pouvait être capté
en n'importe quel point du monde.
Comparé aux satellites
sophistiqués d'aujourd'hui,
Spoutnik était d'une extrême simplicité,
mais ce fut le premier objet
fabriqué par l'homme
à quitter l'atmosphère terrestre.
Le monde était sous le choc.
Pour certains,
cela ouvrait de nouveaux horizons
explorés l'espace,
les planètes et l'univers.
Pour d'autres,
cela annonçait des stations orbitales
menaçant d'anéantir
les villes américaines.
Le 3 novembre, l'URSS continuait
avec Spoutnik deux et Laïka,
l'un des chiens envoyés dans l'espace.
Les scientifiques
mesuraient les modifications
de son rythme cardiaque
et de sa respiration
pour mettre au point
les premiers vols spatiaux habités.
En fait, l'astronautique
existait avant même la révolution russe.
L'un de ses premiers théoriciens
fut Constantin Tsiolkovski,
né en 1857 et mort en 1935.
En 1958, Fidel Castro
prit la tête de la révolution de Cuba
pour abattre un dictateur
de droite corrompu, Batista.
L'Île était dirigée
par de riches propriétaires terriens
et des compagnies américaines.
La capitale, La Havane, était le paradis
du jeu de la prostitution.
Le dictateur et la mafia
se partageaient les bénéfices.
Chacun se réjouit de l'éviction du tyran.
Mais comme pour la révolution russe,
la liberté fut de courte durée.
Castro imposait sa loi.
Des centaines de personnes
accusées de soutenir Batista
furent emprisonnées ou exécutées.
Castro devint l'allié socialiste
de l'U.R.S.S.
Cuba était un protectorat
de l'Union soviétique
qui lui surpayées le sucre et le tabac
afin de compenser l'embargo américain.
Aux Nations unies, Castro se plaignit
que la CIA essayait de le renverser
et avait mis sur écoute
sa chambre d'hôtel à New York.
Personne ne le crut.
Plus tard, à l'ONU, Khrouchtchev
déclara que le communisme
était plus humain que le capitalisme,
que la lutte entre les intérêts financiers
et le peuple finirait
par lui donner raison.
Ce faisant, il prononça la phrase :
"Nous vous enterrons",
qui fut perçu comme une menace.
Cuba ne se trouvant
qu'à 180 kilomètres des côtes américaines,
la guerre semblait toute proche.
Les pacifistes du monde entier étaient
souvent accusés par la CIA ou le FBI
d'être manipulés
à leur insu par le KGB.
Juste avant la conférence de Paris
entre Khrouchtchev
et Eisenhower en 1960,
un avion-espion Yutu fut abattu
au-dessus du territoire soviétique.
Le gouvernement américain nia.
Le Kremlin suivait les élections
présidentielles de 1960 avec intérêt.
John Kennedy était réputé
comme quelqu'un de pragmatique, réfléchi
et peut-être même
facile à manipuler.
Il était moins conservateur
que son adversaire Richard Nixon.
Soviétiques et Américains
ignoraient qu'il préparait
une invasion de Cuba
avec le concours de la CIA,
qui coordonnait les troupes américaines
et les exilés hostiles à Castro.
L'Union soviétique
préparait elle aussi une surprise,
mais nettement plus pacifique.
Dans un centre d'entraînement
à une trentaine de kilomètres de Moscou,
des hommes s'apprêtaient
à vivre une grande aventure,
le lancement
d'une fusée dans l'espace.
Ils s'appelaient les cosmonautes,
les navigateurs du cosmos.
Une gigantesque fusée de lancement
devait décoller d'une base ultrasecrète.
Cette mission prestigieuse
fut confiée au colonel Youri Gagarine,
un jeune pilote de l'armée de l'air,
plein de charme et de séduction,
mais d'une terrible timidité.
Le 12 avril 1961,
il devint le premier
homme dans l'espace.
Gagarine était un pur produit
de l'Union soviétique.
Né le 9 mars 1934
dans un kolkhoze près de Smolensk,
à l'ouest de Moscou.
Il fréquenta l'Institut technique
de Saratov où il apprit à voler.
Brillamment diplômé de l'Académie
de l'armée de l'air soviétique en 1955,
il fut volontaire
pour les vols spatiaux.
Les chercheurs de la Cité de l'Espace,
près de Moscou,
étaient reliés par radio avec la capsule
du jeune cosmonaute de 27 ans.
Le lancement avait été gardé secret,
de peur qu'un accident ne survienne
et ne discrédite le RSS
sur la scène internationale.
La capsule Vostok un effectua
une orbite autour de la Terre,
un exploit que les Américains
ne purent réaliser qu'en février 1962
avec les trois révolutions
de l'astronaute John Glenn.
La capsule de Gagarine
atterrit dans un désert de l'U.R.S.S.
Le risque était plus grand
lorsqu'on se posait en mer,
solution retenue par la NASA,
mais il était plus facile
de garder les vols secrets.
Les Soviétiques
célébrèrent leurs héros.
Une fois encore,
l'URSS dépassait les États-Unis
dans le domaine spatial.
Ce fut un triomphe mondial.
Malheureusement, Gagarine
trouva la mort à 34 ans, en 1968,
son avion s'écrasa près de Moscou
lors d'un vol de routine.
Le programme spatial soviétique
continua à collectionner les records.
Premiers vols inhabités
vers la Lune en 1957.
Premier vol en duo Nicolas
et Fay Popovitch.
Première femme
dans l'espace Valentina Terechkova.
Première station orbitale.
Ces images d'avenir illustraient même
les affiches de propagande omniprésentes.
Les cosmonautes,
objet de fierté nationale,
étaient invitées au plus
grandes cérémonies officielles.
Nikita Khrouchtchev déclara
que l'URSS avait atteint le socialisme
et que l'étape suivante
était le communisme.
C'était le capitalisme,
même sous une forme limitée,
qui permettait
à l'économie de progresser.
Le gouvernement avait autorisé les paysans
à travailler leurs propres lopins
et à vendre
les produits au marché privé.
Avec seulement 3 % des terres,
ils fournissaient
25 % de la production agricole.
La preuve qu'un profit personnel
incitait les gens à travailler plus.
Mais les idées communistes de Lénine
étaient intouchables.
Pour couper encore
plus nettement avec le passé,
Khrouchtchev fit retirer
du mausolée le corps de Staline.
Il fut enterré
dans le cimetière du Kremlin.
Peu importe
la situation économique ou internationale,
les loisirs des Soviétiques
restaient généralement les mêmes.
Les ballets et les opéras du Bolchoï
étaient appréciés
par des gens de tous les âges,
de tous les milieux.
Des pans de la culture populaire
étaient marqués par la propagande.
Les films d'espions
mettaient en scène de beaux
et loyaux agents du KGB
combattant les forces ennemies
de l'impérialisme occidental.
Un James Bond à la russe.
Les films de science-fiction
abordaient souvent
des thèmes pacifistes et pro socialistes.
Dans ce film de science-fiction,
un équipage international
se dirige vers Vénus.
Une fois arrivé,
il voit qu'il y a très longtemps,
cette planète était habitée
par une civilisation
qui s'est détruite en préparant
une attaque nucléaire contre la Terre.
Le football, l'athlétisme,
l'haltérophilie et la santé physique
étaient très importante
pour les Russes.
Pendant des années, les athlètes
remportèrent de nombreuses médailles.
À l'inverse de l'Occident, ces athlètes
étaient pris en charge par l'État
et entraînés
depuis le plus jeune âge.
Le cirque de Moscou fut toujours populaire
en U.R.S.S et dans le monde entier,
faisant des tournées dans toutes les
grandes villes et continents.
La ville de Berlin,
divisée après la Deuxième Guerre mondiale,
se trouvait au cœur
de l'Allemagne de l'Est.
Le blocus communiste fut brisé
par un pont aérien des Alliés en 1949.
Des émeutes furent réprimées
par les chars soviétiques en 1953.
Mais la main-d'œuvre de Berlin-Est
fuyait vers la zone libre.
Pour arrêter
cette hémorragie,
le régime communiste
érigeait un mur de briques
protégées par des fils de fer barbelés
et des mines.
Khrouchtchev visita en personne Berlin
et sembla approuver la construction.
Le mur,
avec ses chiens et ses miradors,
devint un symbole
de l'oppression des États communistes.
Le président Kennedy avait hérité
du projet catastrophique de la CIA
visant à envahir Cuba en 1961.
Le débarquement de la baie des Cochons
fut repoussé par l'armée de Castro
et Kennedy refusa d'engager
une intervention à grande échelle.
En octobre 1962, il récolta les fruits
de cette invasion ratée.
L'Union soviétique fournit à Cuba
des missiles nucléaires de longue portée
destinée à dissuader
d'éventuelles invasions américaines.
Cela signifiait aussi
que Castro pouvait frapper le premier
n'importe quel pays
d'Amérique centrale ou du Nord.
Le ministre soviétique
des Affaires étrangères Andreï Gromyko
niait la présence
de ses fusées à Cuba.
Des vols de reconnaissance confirmèrent
pourtant que les fusées s'y trouvaient
et que beaucoup
étaient opérationnelles.
L'Armée américaine
fut en état d'alerte maximale.
Des bombardiers prirent
position près des frontières soviétiques,
prêts à larguer leurs charges nucléaires
sur des cibles programmées.
Des porte-avions
et des sous-marins équipés
de missiles Polaris encerclèrent Cuba.
Des milliers de troupes
furent mobilisées.
Les bases de Floride
se préparaient à une offensive.
Les probabilités d'une attaque cubaine
étaient bien sûr quasiment nulles.
Mais le moindre faux mouvement,
pouvait déclencher la guerre totale.
Khrouchtchev avait misé que les fusées
ne susciteraient
aucune réaction américaine.
Que les capitalistes comme Kennedy
étaient faciles à intimider.
Le blocus empêcha
que d'autres missiles soient débarqués.
Les faucons du Pentagone
incitaient Kennedy à attaquer Cuba.
Khrouchtchev répondit personnellement
que les missiles allaient être retirés,
mais les partisans de la ligne dure du
Kremlin le poussèrent à changer d'avis.
Les missiles resteraient.
Kennedy et ses conseillers
eurent l'heureuse idée
de ne publier que sa première note,
à deux pas de la catastrophe.
Les deux pays reculèrent.
Kennedy et Khrouchtchev s'étaient
rencontrés à Vienne l'année précédente.
Le leader soviétique avait trouvé
le président américain falot et mou,
mais il pensait sincèrement que le choix
était la coexistence pacifique
ou la guerre totale.
Finalement, un traité interdit
les essais nucléaires dans l'atmosphère.
Le premier pas d'une réduction
dans la course à l'armement.
L'URSS et les États-Unis
encouragèrent tous deux
le développement
du nucléaire civil.
L'Énergie produite par les centrales
fournissait de l'électricité aux viles
sur le vaste territoire soviétique.
Les physiciens russes avaient
bien progressé sur la fission de l'atome,
mais utilisaient souvent
des techniques démodées en Occident.
Dès qu'on a soupçonné
les scientifiques soviétiques
d'utiliser la technologie nucléaire
pour fabriquer des armes,
les progrès réalisés sur les centrales
américaines étaient gardés secrets.
Les deux camps protégeaient jalousement
leurs découvertes et leurs échecs.
Kennedy était fier du résultat
de ces négociations avec l'U.R.S.S.
Chez lui, on l'accusait
d'être à la solde des communistes.
L'interdiction des essais de la bombe H,
refus de l'invasion de Cuba
avec toute la puissance militaire.
La CIA savait même que Kennedy cherchait
à rétablir des relations avec Cuba
et à réduire
la présence militaire au Vietnam.
Kennedy fut assassiné
à Dallas en novembre 1963.
Khrouchtchev
était fier de ce qu'il avait fait,
surtout dans l'industrie
et l'agriculture.
Mais les orthodoxes du Kremlin trouvaient
qu'il avait perdu la face à Cuba
et qu'il était passé à l'ennemi avec le
traité d'interdiction des essais en 1964.
Khrouchtchev fut limogé et Léonid Brejnev
devint premier secrétaire du parti.
Alexeï Kossyguine,
présidant le Conseil.
Au Moyen-Orient, l'Union soviétique
soutenait les pays arabes
contre l'impérialisme sioniste
et avait depuis longtemps établi avec eux
des relations militaires
et industrielles.
En 1960, par exemple,
les Soviétiques aidèrent
le président égyptien Gamal Nasser
à construire le barrage d'Assouan.
Lors de la guerre
de six Jours en 1967,
les avions et les tanks de fabrication
soviétique pilotés par les Égyptiens
ne réussirent pas à contrer les soldats
israéliens armés par les Américains.
Au Vietnam, la guerre du capitalisme
et du communisme continuait.
L'URSS fournissait du matériel
à l'Armée de libération
du Vietnam du Nord,
dirigée par le leader communiste
Hô Chi Minh.
Les États-Unis,
comme souvent,
finirent par soutenir une dictature
militaire fasciste au sud,
tout aussi nuisible
que le régime communiste.
La différence,
c'était que les soldats américains
mouraient par milliers
au combat.
La Chine communiste entra en scène,
ce qui crispa ses relations
déjà tendues avec l'U.R.S.S.
Prudente,
celle-ci n'envoyait pas de troupes.
L'écrivain Alexandre Soljénitsyne,
lauréat du prix Nobel,
révéla au monde entier
l'horreur des camps staliniens
avec l'archipel du Goulag.
Il connut le succès.
En décembre 1979,
l'armée soviétique envahit l'Afghanistan
pour venir en aide
à un jeune régime communiste,
comme jadis en Tchécoslovaquie
et en Hongrie.
On dit aux soldats
qu'il combattait des agents de la CIA,
mais c'était
des moudjahidines afghans.
La guerre continuait
et des milliers de soldats
désillusionnés y laissaient la vie.
L'Afghanistan fut leur Vietnam
et le président Carter
changea d'avis
sur le pacifisme soviétique.
Il y avait encore une possibilité
de paix et de coopération.
Américains et Soviétiques élaborèrent un
programme conjoint dans la stratosphère.
Le 17 juillet 1975,
une capsule soviétique Soyouz
s'arrima
à la station américaine Apollo.
Les trois astronautes
serrèrent la main des deux cosmonautes.
Pendant deux jours,
l'équipage international
mena conjointement des expériences
scientifiques et astronomiques.
Une médaille spéciale
frappée pour l'occasion
symbolisait l'union
des peuples des deux pays.
Les relations entre les chefs
d'Etat américain et soviétique
ont toujours paru cordiales.
Mais ni l'un ni l'autre
ne contrôlait totalement
les industries militaires qui prospèrent
en inventant toujours de nouvelles armes.
Mikhaïl Gorbatchev, entrant en scène,
secrétaire général du Parti communiste,
il savait que son pays avait besoin
de réformes profondes.
Sa femme Raïssa et lui
devinrent connus dans le monde entier.
Il réduisit le budget de la Défense,
ce qui déplut aux militaires,
et il lança une politique
de transparence sur la glasnost.
La censure avait
pratiquement disparu.
Boris Eltsine,
un bon vivant qui ne mâchait pas ses mots,
accompagna Gorbatchev
à sa montée au pouvoir.
Celui-ci rencontra
Ronald Reagan à Genève en 1985.
Sous l'influence conjuguée
du leader soviétique
et de sa femme, Nancy,
Reagan révisa ses préjugés sur l'U.R.S.S.
Nous devrions nous rencontrer
et nous l'avons fait.
J'aspirais à un nouveau départ
et nous l'avons réalisé.
Nous n'étions
peut-être pas d'accord
sur des points idéologiques
ou des objectifs nationaux fondamentaux,
mais nous nous sommes mieux compris
et c'est là une clé pour la paix.
Je peux dire
que le monde est devenu plus sûr.
Gorbatchev était reconnu mondialement
comme un instigateur de la paix,
mais les conditions
économiques
montèrent l'opinion publique
de son pays contre lui.
Eltsine prit ses distances
et quitta le Parti.
L'influence
occidentale se répandit.
Russes,
Géorgiens, Ukrainiens,
tous étaient lassés de ce système
qui offrait si peu de biens matériels,
de ce gouvernement
qui ne les représentait pas.
Bien que Gorbatchev
ait initié la perestroïka,
les citoyens soviétiques étaient plus
intéressés par leur propre sort
que par la situation
internationale.
Le capitalisme
relevait la tête.
Le commerce fleurissait
à tous les coins de rue.
Les jeunes
se mirent au rock and roll.
Comme leurs homologues occidentaux,
les rockers russes chantaient l'amour,
la mort et la révolte.
La musique, les films, les livres
et la télé montrant la vie occidentale
effaçaient nombre de différences
existant entre les jeunes de la Russie
et ceux de l'Ouest.
Les salles de billard et les planches
à roulettes firent leur apparition
et les étudiants avouaient aux étrangers
qu'après leurs examens,
ils s'empressaient d'oublier
tout ce qu'ils avaient appris sur Lénine.
Jadis, le gouvernement central avait tenté
d'effacer toutes les cultures nationales.
Mais l'Arménie, la Géorgie,
les pays baltes
et les républiques d'Asie centrale
s'accrochaient à leurs traditions.
Aujourd'hui, les boîtes de nuit
proposaient des adaptations
d'un folklore séculaire.
Moscou, Leningrad
et surtout les républiques
de Lituanie et de Lettonie
organisèrent des divertissements
qui n'avaient rien
à envier à ceux de Las Vegas
À l'époque de Staline,
ce type d'influence occidentale
était stigmatisé comme décadents,
mais désormais le public en redemandait.
J'ai vu l'avenir et ça marche,
disait un visiteur de l'Union soviétique
dans les années 30.
Mais dans les années 80,
l'avenir se brisa.
À la centrale de Tchernobyl,
des techniciens
testaient le système d'arrêt d'urgence
d'un des réacteurs nucléaires.
En moins de 50 secondes,
la réaction n'était plus maîtrisée.
La température à l'intérieur du réacteur
atteignit plusieurs centaines de degrés.
Le cœur et les parois
se mirent à brûler et à fondre.
Une énorme explosion dispersa plus
d'une tonne de débris radioactifs
mortels dans l'atmosphère.
Parmi les décombres du réacteur,
la matière en fusion continuait à brûler
et à siffler implacablement.
L'Armée rouge, qui avait attendu
de combattre des envahisseurs humains,
dû affronter
un ennemi invisible.
Pour éviter que le sol
et la nappe phréatique
ne soient contaminés
par les radiations,
des ouvriers du métro
construisirent un soubassement
en ciment sous le réacteur.
Le contrôle de l'information
aggrava la situation.
Les responsables de la centrale
perdirent un temps précieux
avant d'admettre
qu'il y avait un problème.
Les autorités locales hésitaient
à alerter le pouvoir central
par crainte des conséquences.
Les volontaires
civils et militaires
qui travaillaient
dans le bâtiment réacteur endommagé,
n'y séjournaient que quinze minutes afin
de prévenir les risques d'irradiation.
Les autorités locales
tentèrent de minimiser le danger.
La population concernée ne fut alertée
que plusieurs heures plus tard,
bien après que des tonnes de déchets
radioactifs se furent échappées.
Même prévenus,
les gens avaient du mal à y croire.
Le gouvernement leur avait assuré que
la centrale ne présentait aucun danger.
L'équipement personnel
furent douchés
pour éliminer les poussières radioactives.
Les forêts proches
furent volontairement incendiées.
Les arbres avaient absorbé beaucoup
de radioactivité qu'ils étaient dangereux.
Des montagnes
de terre radioactive furent retirées
sur les lieux de la catastrophe,
noyées dans du béton et évacuées.
Le caméraman ukrainien
qui filmera les premiers moments
savait ce qu'il risquait,
mais estimait que le monde devait savoir.
Contaminé,
il mourut un an plus tard.
Les poussières radioactives
dépassèrent les limites soviétiques,
gagnant la Finlande,
la Suède et même la Suisse.
En Pologne,
on fit prendre de l'iode aux enfants
pour prévenir les cancers de la thyroïde.
Dans le Grand Nord,
la faune et la flore furent irradiées.
Vivant
de l'élevage des rennes,
les Lapons ne purent plus utiliser
leur peau ni consommer leur viande.
Tchernobyl,
comme Three Mile Island,
relançait la question
de la sécurité nucléaire.
Le jeu
en valait-il la chandelle ?
Les 50 centrales soviétiques
ne fournissaient que
12 % de l'énergie du pays.
Plusieurs responsables de Tchernobyl
furent renvoyés et poursuivis en justice.
L'un d'eux se suicida un an jour
pour jour après la catastrophe.
Le réacteur fut enfermé
dans un énorme sarcophage de béton.
Gorbatchev retira
ses troupes d'Afghanistan.
Cette tentative finit aussi mal
que la présence américaine au Vietnam.
Gorbatchev continuait
à courtiser les États-Unis.
Il était très populaire
quand il se rendit à New York.
Sa volonté de réduire la course
à l'armement fut contrariée
par le projet démesuré
de Ronald Reagan,
qui mettait en œuvre une nouvelle
génération d'armes coûteuses.
C'était l'initiative de défense
stratégique ou la guerre des étoiles.
Ce bouclier théorique aux coûts faramineux
était censé intercepter les missiles
et promettait de relancer
la course à l'armement nucléaire.
L'égalité et la liberté
promise par le communisme
furent prises pour ce qu'elles étaient :
de vaines promesses.
Pressé par le temps, Gorbatchev
encouragea les entrepreneurs
à s'inspirer du modèle occidental,
la propriété privée,
plutôt qu'une industrie
dirigée par l'État.
Mais Gorbatchev croyait encore
au communisme
si le parti était réformé,
la bureaucratie éliminée,
si les États-Unis et l'URSS
s'accordaient pour rejeter
la menace imaginaire de guerre totale,
le système communiste pouvait fonctionner.
Mais ces changements
prendraient du temps.
Pour être sûrs
de disposer du temps nécessaire
et de l'influence suffisante
sur l'immense bureaucratie.
Il nomma alors des conservateurs
de l'époque brejnévienne
à des postes importants.
Des gens qui croyaient encore
au système de Lénine.
C'est en Allemagne
que s'amorça la chute.
Le mur de Berlin tomba,
ouvrant la voie à la réunification
des deux Allemagnes
après 40 ans de séparation.
Puis les peuples de l'Union soviétique
demandèrent à choisir
librement leur destinée.
Au Kremlin, les dirigeants
de toutes tendances hésitaient,
un changement trop grand et trop rapide
engendrerait le chaos.
De trop petits remaniements
déclencheraient une révolte générale.
Gorbatchev comptait sur la confiance
qu'il pensait inspirer,
mais que tous
ne lui accordaient pas.
Eltsine devint le président
de la République russe
lors des premières
élections démocratiques depuis 70 ans.
Ce fut le symbole de la défiance du peuple
envers Parti et le gouvernement central.
Les conservateurs craignaient
que le nouveau pouvoir
ne suscite un élan incontrôlable
qui aboutirait à la division de l'Union
en pays indépendants.
Les émeutes des pays baltes,
apportèrent de l'eau
au moulin des réactionnaires
disant que plus personne
ne maîtrisait la situation.
Un pouvoir ferme devait être rétabli, même
au détriment des libertés individuelles.
En l'espace de deux ans,
quatre millions de personnes
quittèrent le Parti communiste.
Gorbatchev accepta
de réorganiser l'Union soviétique
et d'accorder
l'indépendance aux républiques,
de leur donner une plus grande autonomie
vis-à-vis du pouvoir central.
Certains membres du Soviet suprême
le prirent comme une trahison.
Le week-end précédant
la signature du nouveau traité de l'Union,
Gorbatchev fut fait prisonnier
dans sa résidence de Crimée.
Les présentateurs de télévision
déclarèrent alors que le vice-président
Guennadi Jana F assumait
la charge du gouvernement.
Selon la version officielle,
Gorbatchev était souffrant.
le mensonge était évident,
c'était un coup d'Etat fait
par des hommes prêts à tout.
Baklanov, Premier vice-président
du Conseil de défense.
Clio Choukhov,
président du KGB.
Pavlov, Premier ministre.
Bougault, ministre de l'Intérieur
et Yazoo, ministre de la Défense.
L'Armée entra dans Moscou.
Les nouveaux leaders
proclamèrent un état d'urgence de six mois
pour arrêter l'inflation et les troubles
et restaurer l'ordre et la légalité.
On apprit par la suite
que les putschistes étaient ivres
quand ils se lancèrent
dans cette aventure.
Mais ivres ou non, ils considéraient
que la politique de Gorbatchev
causerait l'effondrement
de l'Union soviétique.
Les chars
entrèrent dans Moscou.
La promesse de la glasnost,
le rêve d'un pays démocratique,
s'évaporait soudain.
Eltsine brava les putschistes,
comme ils avaient bravé Gorbatchev
en exigeant le retour du leader soviétique
et la vérité sur sa prétendue maladie.
Les tenants de la ligne dure
étaient prêts à écraser toute rébellion,
comme ils l'avaient fait en Pologne,
Tchécoslovaquie et Hongrie.
Lech Walesa, connu pour son franc-parler,
restait prudent,
car des troupes soviétiques
stationnaient en Pologne.
Mais les autres chefs d'État,
communistes comme capitalistes,
condamnèrent cette prise de pouvoir
et exigèrent la libération
du président soviétique.
Gorbatchev enregistra ce message
sur sa propre caméra vidéo,
sans savoir
si ce film serait vu un jour.
J'ai essayé deux fois de le joindre
au téléphone, mais sans succès.
Trois jeunes gens furent tués par les
martyrs de la deuxième révolution russe.
Les chars
et les troupes fidèles à Eltsine
entourèrent l'immeuble du Parlement russe
pour parer à une attaque éventuelle.
Des citoyens inquiets
dressèrent des barricades.
À l'intérieur,
les partisans d'Eltsine étaient reliés
au reste du monde par radio,
télévision et fax.
Dehors, dans la nuit des rues de Moscou,
la foule en colère, renverser des autobus
et attaquer les chars, des bâtons,
des pierres et des cocktails Molotov.
Des dizaines de milliers de personnes
se massaient autour du Parlement,
prêtes à affronter les balles,
les bombes et les gaz.
Ils acclamaient
Eltsine qui résistait.
Les soldats ne suivirent pas
le nouveau gouvernement
et passèrent
du côté du peuple.
Même les forces d'intervention spéciales
refusèrent de tirer sur les compatriotes.
Depuis un studio de diffusion
à l'intérieur du bâtiment assiégé,
Eltsine promit
que l'honneur de l'armée russe
ne serait pas souillé
par le sang du peuple.
Les militaires
refusèrent l'autorité des putschistes
et Gorbatchev
put rejoindre le monde extérieur.
J'ai réussi à lui parler,
Gorbatchev est encore en Crimée.
Il rentrera
cette nuit ou demain à Moscou.
Tout le monde connaît le respect
et l'amitié que je lui porte
et j'ai été ravi d'entendre
qu'il allait bien.
Au bout de trois jours,
le putsch avait échoué.
La démocratie triomphait.
Gorbatchev rentra choqué,
mais en bonne santé.
L'Ordre régnait de nouveau,
mais le pouvoir soviétique
était
irrémédiablement ébranlé.
Il était trop tard.
Le marteau et la faucille qui
symbolisaient les paysans et les ouvriers
furent remplacés par le drapeau
tricolore russe d'avant la Révolution
et par les drapeaux
des républiques,
Géorgie, Ukraine,
Moldavie, Estonie, Lituanie.
La statue de Félix Dzerjinski,
le fondateur de la Tchéka, fut enlevée,
ainsi que des monuments
à la gloire de Lénine.
C'était une sorte de répétition sinistre
de la révolution de 1917.
Gorbatchev lui-même
quitta le Parti communiste,
avertit que tout changement brutal
serait fatal au pays.
Eltsine forma néanmoins
une communauté d'États indépendants.
La dernière décision de l'État soviétique
fut de s'auto dissoudre.
Le 25 décembre 1991, Mikhaïl
Gorbatchev démissionna.
C'était le dernier président de l'Union
des républiques socialistes soviétiques.
Les problèmes
d'alimentation demeurent.
L'ouverture soudaine du marché
a fait fortement chuter
la valeur du rouble
et l'avenir suscite
de graves inquiétudes.
après 70 ans de communisme
et 1000 ans de totalitarisme,
le peuple se dirige vers un avenir
incertain, mais plein de promesses.
Les paroles de Gogol
s'appliquent à ce nouveau pays
aussi bien
qu'à la Russie de 1840.
Russie ne voles-tu pas comme une ardente
troïka qu'on ne saurait distancer ?
Tu passes avec fracas dans un nuage
de poussière, laissant tout derrière toi.
Russie où cours-tu ?
L'air bouleversé s'agite
et devient vent.
Tout ce qui se trouve sur terre
est dépassé et avec un regard d'envie.
Les autres nations s'écartent
pour te livrer passage.